for a lot of people consciousness is
ultimately
connected to a self
i mean
that's our our experience of
consciousness is very
it's connected to this ego i mean i just
i mean what else could it possibly be i
can't even how do you begin to
comprehend to visualize
to conceptualize a consciousness that's
not connected to like this particular
organism
we'll have a way of thinking about this
whole problem now that's that's that
comes out of this this framework that's
different
so
we can imagine a dynamics of
consciousness
not in space and time just
abstractly
it could be cooperative for all we know
it could be very friendly i don't know
but it and you can set up a dynamics
a markovian dynamics that is so called
stationary and that's a technical term
which means that the entropy effectively
is not increasing there is some entropy
but it's constant so there's no
increasing entropy
and in that sense
the dynamics is timeless
there is no entropic time
but it's a trivial theorem
three line proof
that if you have a stationary markovian
dynamics any projection that you make of
that dynamics by conditional probability
and if you want i can state a little bit
more even more mathematically precisely
for for some readers or listeners but if
any projection you take by conditional
probability
the induced
image of that markov chain
will have increasing entropy
you will have entropic time so so i'll
be very very precise so i have
a markov ch chain x1 x2 through xn where
x n goes to infinity right
[Music]
the entropy h
capital h of x n is equal to the entropy
h of x n minus 1 for all n
so the entropy is the same
but
it's a it's a theorem that h of x n
say given x sub 1
is greater than or equal to h of x n
minus 1
given x 1.
sure where does the greater come from
because with the theorem the three-line
proof
h of x n
given x one
is greater than or equal to h of x n
given x one and x two because
conditioning reduces
but then h of xn
minus 1
given
x1 comma x2
is equal to h of xn
given x2 xn minus 1 given x2
by the markov property
and then because it's
stationary it's equal to
h of x um
um
i have to write it down next time sure
anyway there's a three-line proof sure
so
but the assumption of stationarity
we're using a lot of times that people
will understand right doesn't matter the
uh so so there's some kind of some
markovian dynamics is uh
basically trying to model some kind of
system with some probabilities and
there's agents and they interact in some
kind of way and you can say something
about that system as it involves uh
stationarity so
stationary
uh
system is one that has certain
properties in terms of entropy
very well but we don't know if it's
stationary now we don't know what
properties
uh right uh you have to kind of take
assumptions and see okay well what is
what does the systems behave like
under these different properties the the
more constraints the more assumptions
you take the more predictive the more
interesting powerful things you can say
but sometimes they're limiting
that said we're talking about
consciousness here
how does that
you said cooperative okay competitive
it just i like chocolate i'm sitting
here i have a brain i'm wearing a suit
it sure as hell feels like i'm myself
right
now what am i tuning in am i plugging
into something
am i a projection a simple trivial
projection into space-time from some
much larger organism that i can't
possibly comprehend how the hell you're
saying some yes you're building up
mathematical intuitions fine great but
i'm just i'm i'm having an existential
crisis here and i'm going to die soon
we'll all die pretty quickly so i i want
to
i want to figure out why chocolate is so
delicious
uh so help me out here so let's just
keep sneaking up to this right so
the whole technical technical thing was
to say this
even if the dynamics of consciousness is
stationary so that there is no entropic
time
any
projection of it any
view of it
will have the artifact
of entropic time
that's a limited resource
limited resources
so that the fundamental dynamics may
have no limits limited resources
whatsoever any projection will have
certainly time is a limited resource and
probably a lot of other limited
resources hence we could get
competition and evolution and nature red
and tooth and claw as an artifact of a
deeper system in which those aren't
fundamental and and in fact
i take it as
something that this theory must do
at some point is to show how networks of
conscious agents even if they're not
resource limited give rise to evolution
by natural selection via a projection
yeah but you're saying
i'm trying to understand how the limited
resources that give rise to
um
so first the thing gives rise to time
that gives rise to limited resource that
gives rise to
evolution by natural selection how that
has to do with the fact that chocolate
is delicious
well well it's not going to do that
directly it's going to get to this
notion of self so oh oh it's going to
give you the notion of so evolution
gives you the notion of self
and also of of of a self separate from
other selves so so the idea would be
that competition has life and death all
those kinds of things that's right so it
it won't i i don't think
as i said i don't think that i can tell
you how the formless gives rise to the
experience of chocolate
right now my current theory says that's
that's one of the miracles i'm assuming
yeah that's so my theory can't do it and
the reason my theory can't do it is
because hoffman's brain can't do it
right now
[Laughter]
but but the notion of self yes
the notion of self can be an artifact
of the projection
of it so there's one conscious agent
because anytime conscious agents
interact they form a new conscious agent
so there's one conscious agent
any projection of that one conscious
agent gives rise
to time even if there wasn't any time in
that one conscious agent
and it gives rise i i want to now i
haven't proven this so this is so now
this is me guessing where the theory is
going to go not i haven't done this
there's no paper on this yet so now i'm
speculating my guess is i'll be able to
show or the or the my brighter
colleagues working with me will be able
to show
that that we will get evolution of
natural selection the notion of
individual selves individual physical
objects and so forth coming out as a
projection of this thing and and that
the self
this then will be be really interesting
in terms of how it starts to interact
with certain
um spiritual traditions right where they
will say that there is a notion of self
that needs to be let go which is this
finite self that's competing with other
selves to you know get more money and
prestige and so forth that self in some
sense has to die but there's
a deeper self which is the timeless
um
being
that preclude that precedes not
precludes but precedes um any particular
conscious experiences the ground of all
experience that there's that notion of a
deep capital self but our little
lowercase s selves could be artifacts of
projection
and
it may be that
what consciousness is doing in this
framework is right it's projected itself
down
into a self that calls itself dawn and a
self that calls itself lacks
and
through conversations like this it's
trying to find out about itself
and eventually transcend
the limits of the don and lex
little icons that it's using
and and that little projection of itself
through this kind of conversation is
somehow it it's learning about itself
so that that thing dressed me up today
in order to understand itself
and in some sense you and i are not
separate from that thing and we're not
separate from each other yeah
well i have to question the fashion
choices on my end
you